hey you do you like nature documentaries
and zelda then i have good news for you
if you're interested to see what it's
like to live as a pokablin and study
their behavior check out this video i
made recently
link in the description and the end card
so go check it out
[Music]
deciding what is canon and what isn't
isn't always
easy we know third party materials like
the cartoons cdi games and mangas
aren't canon since they were not made by
nintendo but then we have stuff like
creating a champion which also isn't
made by nintendo but it is an official
publication which is greenlit by the big
n
and even then some stuff in the book is
widely accepted to be canonical but we
also find
elements that have been retconned or
changed by age of calamity or left up to
the player to decide
like i said it isn't always
straightforward even the official
timeline has a footnote that states that
it's still
up to the player's imagination out of
all zelda games breath of the wild might
be the most divisive due to the
inclusion of so many additional content
stuff like the amiibos the dlc and not
to mention the freedom and open nature
of the game itself
it's one of the reasons why series
producer aj onuma has been reluctant to
say anything about the game's placement
in the zelda timeline
stating things like quote we revealed
where each zelda game fell on a timeline
and how their stories relate but we
didn't do that for breath the wild
we realized that people were enjoying
imagining the story that emerged from
the fragmentary imagery we were
providing
if we defined a restricted timeline then
there would be a definitive story and it
would eliminate the room for imagination
which wouldn't be as fun although this
might not be the answer a zelda lore
detective is looking
for i do understand the numerous
philosophy here after all breath of the
wild can be completed in so many ways
and depends on whether or not you got
all the memories completed all 120
shrines and how many divine beasts you
conquered
if any at all say i free every champion
from their divine beast
except for rivali because sweet revenge
for 100 years ago you arrogant oversized
drumstick
is that canon to my story probably not
and i think most people agree that the
quote-unquote true breath the wild story
is the one where link completes all the
main story missions since although the
game is
open-ended this is still the narrative
the game tries to push you towards this
includes getting the master sword all
your memories freeing the champions all
that good stuff
and then we have all the extra content
we'll talk about amiibo another time
since i feel like they deserve their own
separate video but when it comes to dlc
i think the story edition should
probably be considered canon
there's just too many important
revelations here to simply brush them
off as meaningless extras
examples of this being the trial of the
sword which sees link now with the fully
restored master sword and being able to
hear phi's voice within the sword
this is a pretty big deal and i'd argue
is too important not to be considered as
part of the main narrative
the same thing goes for the inclusion of
the fifth divine beast and the
introduction of monk boss koshia at the
end
as for the rest of the dlc well there's
a lot to take into consideration
some of which are obviously just nods
and references like rex's salvager
outfit from xenoblade and the nintendo
switch
shirt while others are nice expansions
to link's abilities such as the travel
medallion which i have no problems with
being considered canon
it's just another chica relic after all
and it doesn't stray away from what
should be possible in the game's story
which brings us to one piece of the dlc
which although has
all the characteristics of being nothing
more than a reference could actually be
canonical when we take a closer look at
it
i'm of course talking about the
treasures of misco the great bandit
oh hold on did i hear someone say bandit
oh hey mass nintendo bandit i didn't
know you were here even though i had to
animate this phone call in advance
but anyway what's up heard you were
talking about bandits and i thought
what better way to discuss a topic like
this than with yours truly
you know the masked nintendo bandit
can't argue with that
take it away will do sir the reason why
the misco treasure hunt found in dlc
pack 1
and 2 stands out from the other
collectibles is that it actually ties
into an already
established lore piece from the base
game the side quest that's fittingly
titled misco
the great bandit i'm pretty sure most
fans will be familiar with it since the
side quest itself is found inside the
dueling peak stable which is likely one
of the first places you encounter if you
follow king rome's directions and head
straight for kakariko right after
leaving the great plateau
you talk to these two guys grease some
palms and then they give you a riddle to
solve which leads to a treasure
allegedly belonging to this infamous
bandit
misco who this guy actually is or was is
actually something that we're going to
discuss further in
my part of the collab in this video
we're going to focus on the loot he
managed to acquire over the span of his
badass bandit career
we have the phantom armor midness helmet
korok mask and majora's mask in dlc pack
1
and the lobster shirt ravio's hood zanz
helmet
phantom ganon armor and royal guard
uniform in dlc pack 2.
obviously if we had to explain where
each and every one of them came from and
how they may have all transcended from
their respective games into
breath of the wild we would be here all
week they could all probably have an
entire theory video devoted to them
just trying to explain how and why but
the main point here is that although
they could be considered as
nods to the past and nothing more there
is actually very little standing in the
way of their inclusion being canonical
to the franchise
let's take the majoris mask for example
yes the evil entity known as
majora has left the mask by the end of
the game but the mask itself
still exists and was likely taken back
to hyrule by the happy mask salesman
when he departed termina since
well that's where he originated from in
the first place the mask has
obviously lost most of its power since
then and judging from the fact that the
moon isn't growing an angry face in
breath of the wild
it's safe to assume that this is still
the case after all these countless years
the same thing could be said about many
if not all the other artifacts that make
up misco's fortunes no matter how far
fetched there's always a way to explain
these relics still persisting to this
day
whether it's because they were never
completely destroyed or lost in the
first place or maybe it's a replica made
to remember
honor or memorialize a specific event or
individual who knows which is why the
backstory behind the misco dlc side
quest
does make sense canonically the relics
are described to have originally been in
the possession of the royal family of
hyrule before they were nabbed by misco
at some point in time
each and every one of these artifacts
has some degree of historical
significance so if anything
it would make less sense for the royal
family not to preserve them
similar to how in our own world we have
relics on this place some of which
hundreds of thousands of years old the
hylians may have been doing the same
thing
throughout history these ancient objects
could have been passed down from one
person to the next or replicated until
they ultimately land in the hands of
hyrule's leadership
yes even tingle's outfit can be
considered as such despite his
strange demeanor he did in fact aid the
various heroes of hyrule on multiple
occasions across the timeline
he is as much a historical figure as any
so in a sense hyrule castle housed a
museum of some kind a place where these
ancient relics from the distant past
were kept
but unlike a museum it is more likely
that these weren't open to the public
but only accessible to those close to
the royal family
very similar to the vaults of vatican
city of which most of its contents are
still a mystery to this day and are ripe
for all kinds of theories
from the magical like the holy grail and
the ark of the covenant to flat out
crazy alien illuminati conspiracy
theories to the more realistic stuff
like letters and leftovers from
historical figures it's definitely not
too far-fetched to think that the royal
family have these ancient objects stored
away somewhere
until misco ultimately managed to break
in and take off with some of it the
royal family has historically been
very serious about passing down and
preserving all kinds of magical
artifacts
stuff like the ocarina of time for
instance which kind of makes you think
do these vaults still reside in hyrule
castle right now if so
what else could be hidden there it's
unlikely that misco managed to clean up
the whole place right there have been
many speculations about the
disappearance of certain important
objects
like the aforementioned ocarina of time
for instance which isn't ever seen again
after the events of majora's mask
maybe link did eventually return it to
the royal family after his trip to
termina but just think about that for a
moment
the famous ocarina of time could be
right here hidden
somewhere within the walls of hyrule
castle right now if
only we could get to it but hey maybe
we'll find out more in a certain sequel
to breath of the wild
with all that said though one question
remains who
is or was misco the great bandit what
was his motivation and where is he now
is he long gone or is he still among us
somewhere
well there is the fact that his journal
just shows up and
no spoilers we will dive deeper into the
mystery of the great bandit himself over
on my channel masked nintendo bandit
yeah that seems fair right you are sir
so if you're interested in finding out
the identity of
misco the great bandit follow the link
in the description below to head on over
to the video that's already live over on
my channel
it also features your main man monster
maze of course you heard the man
anyway a big thanks to mass nintendo
bandit for joining me on this one
it's always fun working with you thanks
so much for having me man it's always a
pleasure to work together on videos
if you guys are interested in more zelda
theories or other kinds of nintendo
nonsense
head on over to my channel and check me
out this is masintonabanet signing out
and as always a big thanks to you for
watching and who could forget my
gracious patreon supporters and channel
members we got some new faces so say
hello to
jeff shepstone rachelan ipkiss mr
redbanana
thanks for joining on the minecraft live
stream by the way and andres monge
rodriquez
so sorry if i butchered your name and
that is all for today
i hope to see you in the next one we
have the next part of the evolution of
hyrule coming up soon
so join me then if you will this is dawn
signing off and
have a good one
[Music]
you